my name is Kevin Bailey and I'm a visual
effects artist I got my start when I was
18 years old in the industry on Star
Wars The Phantom Menace and have since
worked on movies like Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire
transformers age of extinction and a
whole bunch of movies with Robert
Zemeckis we're here today to talk about
the five visual effects Academy Award
nominees and what makes them so
groundbreaking what's really exciting to
me is a visual effects artist about this
year's field of nominees is how diverse
they are some years you have three or
four really similar films and one kind
of stands above the rest and it's an
easy guess this year it's everything
from digital characters 2d aging to
invisible effects virtual production
every film stands for something
different
[Music]
first let's look at Avengers and game
Avengers endgame which is a whole tie up
to the Marvel comic universe really
built upon successes of previous Marvel
films with their digital characters
Thanos was an amazing performing digital
character an infinity war that made use
of machine learning and all kinds of
cool tech to bring him to life in that
film and they just elevated that
technology to a whole new level and not
only was there Thanos in this film we
also had smart Hulk right so we had
multiple digital characters that were
performing and moding that the audience
could really connect with in previous
Marvel movies the Hulk has always been
this sort of raging stupid the
embodiment of anger and he didn't really
have to connect with the audience on any
other level than that with Smart Hulk in
Avengers end game he actually has got
his wits about it maybe smashed a few
things along the way I think it's good
to hear this but whatever
and he's sitting there performing
alongside his live-action actors and
needs to be up to the very same level as
them with every nuance of performance
that he gives and now the best of both
worlds there was a pretty amazing
technology that went into bringing fan
OHS and smart Hulk to life in Avengers
endgame the past there's been you know
techniques use where there's thousands
of dots on an actor's face and every
single one of them is trying to drive
like a little piece of digital
characters performance but there's
always stuff that happens in between the
dots that we miss right and we end up
with this kind of uncanny valley effect
with digital characters well by using
machine learning they spent a lot of
times actually teaching the computer how
these faces should move and then when
the actor goes to perform with these
head mounted cameras on they're actually
not capturing that much data they're
just sort of getting the gist of what
the actors doing when I had to go but
the stones I really tried to bring her
back and they feed that to the machine
learning algorithm and it analyzes what
the face is doing and it effectively
fills in the blanks and translates that
to smart Hulk's performance so they
actually use a lot of different sets of
input data what we call it training data
to learn how an actor's face should move
so there's a very very high resolution
scan of the actor's face that's hundreds
of cameras multiple lights that tell us
not only how their face is shaped but
how their skin reacts to different kind
of light hitting it and then we also put
them through what we call facial range
of motions right which is then going
through every expression you can
possibly imagine it's actually very
tiring going through this but what it
allows us to do is to see down to a poor
level of detail what their skin does in
three dimensions as they go from a smile
to a frown for example terabytes of data
go into the input to train the machine
learning algorithm
and that allows us to actually not
capture a lot of data on set then we can
correlate that small amount of data with
this intense data set that we have for
training to create an incredibly rich
performance of a fully digital character
in addition to these stunning digital
characters in avengers endgame there are
entire worlds that are designed from
scratch is sort of out of people's
imagination built down to every blade of
grass and doing that in a level that is
consistent across an entire film and
this film had 2,500 individual shots
that had visual effects in them to make
that consistent across the whole film as
a huge huge task on this scale and they
really nailed it
no one does
[Music]
[Applause]
I do
starwars the Rison Skywalker was a film
that really played heavily on nostalgia
from a visual effects perspective in a
storytelling perspective not only did
the visual effects team have to kind of
build on this Star Wars universe that
we've become so used to seeing and to
have it feel really authentic and
physical and gritty and grounded but
they had to bring multitudes of digital
and actually live-action puppets to life
Star Wars has always been groundbreaking
from a technology perspective but it's
also always been grounded in reality
right the world just feels tactile and
in this film they went to huge lengths
to pay respect to how the original films
were made they used tons of practical
models and actual physical set builds in
addition to a lot of digital techniques
that are cutting-edge even for today
that real blend of physical with state
of the art is part of the Star Wars DNA
one of the biggest challenges we always
have in deciding how we're going to film
the movie is deciding what's gonna be
real versus what's going to be digital
in the scene that takes place on the
sunken Death Star Roger guy yet the
visual effects supervisor and his team
had to decide what water should be real
versus what should be digital and they
ended up doing the vast majority of the
water digitally they actually created an
entirely new ocean pipeline in order to
be able to execute those shots but not
all of the water was digital one of the
really important things for us as a
visual effects team is to make sure that
the actors always have context to help
with their performances and especially
when it's something that they need to
touch having something there for real
like having these waves that are
crashing over them be there for real is
critical to achieving a believable
illusion a really touching part of Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker was seeing
Carrie Fisher on screen again playing
Princess Leia posthumously instead of
using the digital facial techniques that
are heavily used by some of the other
contenders this year they opted to use
Carrie Fisher's real face
film from footage from past films and
augment it with digital hair and the
digital body around her so that she fit
into her environment I think that that
really helped carries soul come out on
screen and it was really appropriate for
that moment right so Thanos absolutely
deserves to be a digital character carry
in this film there the only way to do
her was to actually use her since my
days as an 18 year old on Star Wars
Episode one digital effects have come so
so far back then we really had to be
restrictive about how we use the effects
so digital characters were incredibly
difficult to achieve we have to make
sure that the camera wasn't moving too
much in any one shot otherwise it would
make the shots take a long time and be
way too expensive now we're sort of
freed up to be able to do almost
anything that we can imagine and so what
filmmakers are challenged with these
days is not to ask whether something can
be done which is what we faced back in
the days of Star Wars Episode one but
should it be done and how does it
service the story and I think Star Wars
has evolved as a franchise to be a great
example of a film that uses the right
tool for the right job
in your arms oh I'm gentleman must be
something big if the channels here
they're walking into a trap
your orders are to deliver a message
calling off tomorrow morning's attack if
you don't get there in time
we will lose 1,600 men
19:17 is a movie that you might not look
at and say oh that's the visual effects
movie you would be sorely mistaken it is
full of visual effects beginning to end
the whole movie plays as one continuous
shot where there's no cuts that you can
actually see in the film and that
required an immense amount of work from
the visual effects team the film was
actually shot in several different
locations
some of them outdoors some of them
inside on sound stages over the course
of several months and so how do you make
that all look like one that's seamless
piece of storytelling between each piece
of footage shot on different days in
different places digital effects artist
had to seamlessly blend from one to the
next in a way that the audience can
actually perceive it one of the more
dramatic examples of one of these
digital blends is a scene where our hero
character is running out of a village
that's on fire away from gunman jumps
off a bridge and into a river and then
floats down the river as the actor came
around and jumped off the bridge he was
transitioned to a fully digital actor
until he lands in the water and then he
became that same actor but on a
different day in a different place so
just that one example is thousands of
man-hours of visual effects time to
bring that to life in addition to all of
the digital blends what a lot of people
don't realize is how much digital work
is done to actually plus out this world
war one period world where tanks that
are stuck in giant craters they're
actually fully digital they were never
built for real big fields that have tons
of spent ammunition strewn all over very
little of that was actually real and it
all felt incredibly grounded it felt
like it was really there and to me those
kinds of effects what we call invisible
visual effects that are there to support
the story rather than be the story are
some of my favorite kinds of effects
was like the army you followed orders
you did the right thing
you got rewarded the Irishman featured
one specific technique that is what
gotten it nominated for an Oscar that is
the D aging of some of the most
well-known and well-loved actors of our
time and to do that for the entire film
without falling into the uncanny valley
is a massive challenge what the visual
effects supervisor Pablo Hellman and his
team did on that film was to actually
really use the actors facial expressions
on a movie set as ground truth and they
made a digital mask effectively that
went over that actor's face to make
these digital masks move perfectly they
filmed every actor with not one camera
but three we had the main camera that
was the normal camera that you would use
to shoot a movie and then we had to what
we call witness cameras on either side
and between those three cameras and a
special piece of software that
industrial light magic wrote called flux
they were able to actually analyze every
movement of an actor's face flux was
actually able to figure out what each
actor was doing exactly create the
younger version of them and then that
would be superimposed on the older
version of the actor and that became the
final result it was really important to
Martin Scorsese to be able to shoot this
like a normal movie without motion
capture right he didn't want a bunch of
technology getting in the way of the
process so the two cameras the witness
cameras that are on either side of the
main camera they actually shoot infrared
footage because that allows the visual
effects team to light the scene in a way
that allows those cameras to actually
see the actor we can't see infrared
light so we can just pump in visual
infrared light into the set and see
really clearly what the actors are doing
even though Scorsese wants to light it
as like a really dark moody scene
so what the irishman visual effects team
did was actually brilliant is that they
figured out how to get out of the way of
the filmmaking process
of this you know genius and Scorsese to
get all the data that they needed a
really important part of bringing these
younger versions of these actors to life
was actually using thousands of images
and video clips from each actor in their
younger days so that they can not only
build a face that looks like kind of
what we remember them to have looked
like in the past but also to help train
algorithms within the flux software to
make the faces move authentically when
watching the irishman for all three and
a half hours of the movie I actually
felt like they were really successful in
bringing these younger versions that the
actors to life there was some criticism
about you know the the posture of the
actors was a little more like an old man
than it was the younger version of
yourself and to be honest I think the
sign of success with any effect is
whether it helps to engage you in the
movie or if it bumps you out of the
movie and for the duration of the
irishman I was just fully engaged in
those characters so the little technical
flaws of in this instance posture
they just didn't stand out to me I've
heard a lot of actors talk about the
Irishman as giving them a new lease on
life right the fact that these actors
could perform as younger versions of
themselves and do so so convincingly I
think has pretty big ramifications for
storytellers moving forward we can now
look at casting actors based on their
personality and they're fit for a role
unless for their age some people talk
about the ethical concerns of being able
to create a digital version of any actor
out there and I was like oh are we gonna
have replace actors one day and I think
the Irishman is proof positive that
that's just not gonna happen it's
nonsensical there is no amount of
digital wizardry I promise you this that
is gonna bring a performance to the
level that a De Niro is going to bring
to the screen right and that foundation
that soul of the actor that's what we're
responding to from an emotional
perspective and as the Irishman proved
to us the digital wizardry
more than replacing an actor's
performance it's complementing it it's
actually helping to highlight it and
build upon it and that as a storyteller
is an incredibly exciting prospect to
leverage more and more into the future
in the Lion King Rob legato the visual
effects supervisor and his team created
an entirely digital world for the story
to take place in in fact there's only
one shot in the movie the opening shot
that was filmed in Africa everything
else is completely virtual but it feels
like real life it feels like you're
watching a National Geographic
documentary now the danger of having a
completely virtual world that you can do
anything you want in is that it could
end up looking like a video game no
matter how realistic the grass looks if
the camera is not moving correctly and
if the lighting isn't cinematic it's
just not gonna work so what Rob legato
and his visual effects team did on the
film is they designed virtual production
tools that allowed real camera teams
with real camera cranes and dollies and
steadicams that were puppeteering these
digital cameras in the virtual world and
so what you end up with is a feel of the
movie that is every bit as naturalistic
as if it had been shot in the African
plains the thing that's always a dead
giveaway with digital effects is when
things are too perfect right the natural
world it has a certain amount of chaos
that is completely unavoidable and by
using virtual production and real camera
equipment to design these digital camera
moves that imperfection that we're so
used to seeing in cinema is translated
onto these digital African plains so
that it just looks like something that
we're used to seeing predicting who's
gonna take home the Oscar this year is
and I'm not copping out here it's just
totally impossible all of the films that
are nominated are so different and I
really think that the winner is going to
be probably the story that ended up
connecting with audiences the moat